welcome everybody another YouTube
hangout super excited to be here with a
longtime friend mr. grant cardone mr. G
C's got a new book coming out be
obsessed or be average it drops in four
days and so we're going to talk about
obsession and how it's important in your
business grant welcome aboard man Evan
good to see man been too long buddy
grant is in Miami hainsley be that big
or hurricane there yeah I got people I
mean I've been streaming today I've been
streaming the the hurricane coming up
here it was on MSNBC that this frickin
wacko job in the 33rd floor of regalia
right where the storms hit in his
streaming live so I love it hey there's
always an opportunity to drop some value
and spread some love yeah yeah talk to
me about this book man what's it all
about what's the deal well dude this is
my seventh book it's my 19th a business
program or sales book and and uh this
really is a story about my life kind of
where I came from and you know you know
people have called me a sales guy and
they've called me a real estate guy and
an author and a speaker and all that
stuff but really really my whole life
turned around when I when it when I
rather than denying some of my crazy
obsessions
you know Steve Carlos you and I friends
with Steve these guys probably don't
know Steve and Hank but you know Steve
always tells me do you - craziest dude I
ever met man and I said you know I've
heard that my whole life when I when I
when I was 10 and 12 years old my
friends do my mom told my friends don't
hang out with my son I was it was I was
always crazy and uh and then uh and
every time I tried to resist who I am
and like I got this category for you
this hit in Miami that we didn't leave
I'm like not want to stay and see the
action now take care of myself I make
sure everything's cool but when I denied
that I have this thing that I think
everybody's got and then frankly I think
everybody's got this this thing to be a
little crazy right when I denied it I
got in trouble it all just kind of came
out in crazy ways whether it was drugs
or you know
wrong girls or doing the wrong stuff
hanging out with the wrong people and
then when I was 25 I'm like dude if I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die being who I am
mmm and because between 16 and 25 my
life looked terrible and then when I
just started owning Who I am just being
Who I am just telling people like you
know you know I kind of cocky I am you
know I got a big mouth man say whatever
I want you know people don't like it I
know they don't like it but the problem
is I didn't like not being me you know
and when I did when I wasn't being me
you know I can't remember a time when I
didn't want to be rich and I can't
remember time in my life when I didn't
want to be famous but if you tell
anybody that man you walk out and tell
anybody that you know I want to be rich
dude watch watch the repercussions watch
watch the people freaking yank on you
for saying that and so be obsessed for
me it's really about my life man I mean
I'm either I'm either gonna be obsessed
with the things that I'm doing or I end
up kind of getting muted down and
deluded to talk to something a lot less
than my potential so what happened at 25
that meet that shift like nine years of
not having a great life or getting the
trouble and then BOOM like what happened
what sparked to change well when I was
16 I started using drugs and when I was
25 I was using drugs 15 times a day and
I tried to quit for nine years everyday
for nine years so so then I went to a
treatment center because my mom's like
hey don't even come around everybody
gave up on it like everybody this didn't
this isn't some kind of pull and hard
story this is like dude people hated me
man okay and the worst part of it is I
did I hated me so it wasn't that I was
broke and I didn't have a job at all
about all the bad stuff but did the
feeling that I had about myself you know
was just awful so I went to the
treatment center you know and got off
the drugs quit quit using drugs for 25
days and they told me I had to leave
because the insurance was was over what
a scam that
is and uh and the counselor dude I don't
even remember his name but he told me on
the way out he's like hey man let me
tell you something cuz she I don't know
if you've ever gone to one of these
12-step kind of deals but you go in and
you do like this huge introspection on
yourself and then you got to share with
the group all your stuff so I'm telling
these guys that I want to be rich and I
think I'm I'm James Bond on the on the
reincarnation of James Bond and you know
I'm gonna you're right looks dude imma
be famous man and people gonna see me
and I'm gonna do all this well every
time you do that over there they're like
no no give up on the ego give up on
grandiosity you're not gonna be rich if
you just don't use drugs one day at a
time then you need to be happy the guy
told me on the way out of the place he's
like look if you don't give up on all
that you'll never make it
hmm and I walked out there and said dude
I'm gonna get rich I'm gonna get rich
I'm gonna get famous and because I am
dude I just couldn't live a life for
just not doing drugs because I don't
think drugs would my problem you know it
was just a symptom of something else
that when arrived and and so when I went
back I took that addictive that you know
that 15 times a day and not trying to
use drugs dude I took that energy and I
threw it in work and you know how I work
dude I'm a maniac
you know so so I took it and I basically
people started tell me y'all you just
replace one addiction with with another
addiction and I'm like yeah that's
exactly what I did
I replaced one addiction with another
and now now I get addicted to the good
things in my life I love it so is it
that that you want you have a black and
white of meat back there in the
background and I got to get you a big
black it might not the goal a hey well
we got Kanye on there so you know either
we'll see we'll see
I'll let there you go hit the hoodie on
yeah was that the turning point like
going into that that well I don't know I
don't know you know
no for me there's not been one turning
point you know there's been a lot of
turning points in my life because you
know when I was 25 I was busted broke
beat up but when I was 30 when I was 35
dude I was busted and broke broke up
again even though I had money now I
didn't haven't used drugs in ten years I
had money I had two businesses [ __ ] I
was and booming I felt like I felt like
I spiritually depleted I was burning out
um and again man I felt like I was in a
similar place and so for me like I hear
a lot of people talk about one purpose
the one thing you know one thing has
never filled me up whether it was one
friend one drug whatever dude one
doesn't work for me one wife is good
that's all I need I love my kids one
family you know but but I've always
needed something else you know I need I
need something else to fill me up you
know and there was a I'm 35 years old
and these people are like dude when are
you ever going to be satisfied I heard
that a lot when's enough enough you know
why can't you just enjoy what you have
what's right like something was wrong
with me and I bought it I bought those
ideas I talked about this in the book
about feeding feeding the beast and
starving starving fear and I kept
hearing about this you know what you're
never going to be satisfied nothing
fills you up and that's why you're so
disappointed and people would say things
like don't have high expectations you
know Sam Walton said the only way to
live a life is with high expectations
the only way to achieve anything is with
high expectations but something happened
in American between 1980 and 2000 where
where everybody started doing this
introspection feel your feelings with
the chick's name over it Steve Carlos's
place the coach over there uh Terry no
no the one that the one that says go go
inside what what was your name and I
used to one time I said did you do this
um because it's just not who I am like
like I'm done I'm done so much interest
affection that I couldn't do anything I
had become immobilized my purposes I
mean what's wrong with somebody that
wants to do another thing you know that
that look I am NOT filled up by one
person my wife cannot feel me up
two kids can't make me feel full because
I think that people are obsessed with a
lot of purposes and that's why people
are dissatisfied and my goal is that
this book gives people permission to be
to not be so introspective but to
actually become obsessed with dreams
again with possibilities with the idea
that you could be a husband a father a
community leader a church leader you
could actually talk about politics you
could get rich you could write books you
could find time to do all that and not
even worry about balance because the
obsession of each one of those things
would actually fill you up to have a
life that was that was naturally
balanced so you're getting a lot of like
you're getting a lot of love in the in
the chat people hope you're okay in
Miami with the the weather and yeah
uncle G uncle G C in the house and a lot
a lot of love and chatter going on
that's up but you know people have
really helped me with the book I mean
we're number number three four and six
at a top ten on Amazon under
entrepreneurship and all the other books
have been released already so I mean I
got top ten audio top ten eReader top
ten top two in books and and nobody's
even gotten the book yet so not my fan
base do people that love me man
or they love the title dude I think I'm
hitting all the junkies out there
freaking though that the guys that are
freaking junkies and the chicks that
want the right guy and the people that
actually do want to get rich I know you
don't hear anybody walk around saying
dude I want to get rich I mean stupid
stupid rich what I can just I could I
can just send I can just give ten
million away and not worry about who
talks about that nobody do this tab
you know and and uh I always wanted
access my whole life I wanted access to
somebody you know I want to see the
inside once somebody makes it but most
people they close they close the
curtains you know guys man they make it
big and the next thing you can't get to
it's like they closed off a little bit
and I understand cuz you start getting a
lot of hate you know you start getting a
lot of I mean I don't know if you
getting any negativity today or not but
you can start you know you could start
tolling it a lot of noise particularly
the way the Internet is so many people
could be anonymous today where you're
getting a lot of love Tilt Nilmar ease
reading in finally a book that
understands how I feel so it's good
people thankful feeling it yeah here's a
question see God you know there's a lot
of people who have I call them the
little man in their life we've got these
people who you know just hate on you and
tell you it's not going to work out and
go be normal and give up on your dream
you can't do it and then maybe they
listen to this interview and it sparks
something or they pick up your book and
it sparks something but then after they
go back like they still hang out with
these people and like how do you keep it
consistent how do you keep you have that
fire but everybody around you telling
you how it's not going to work out I
didn't keep on that horse every day and
be consistent following that crazy
obsession that nobody believes in but
you yeah you got it you got to start
grabbing people that that won't put you
down for you know and the way the way to
find out if you have the right group
there's an exercise in the book that
says look you just take a piece of paper
and you're going to put obsessed people
that you're associated with these are
maniacs dude they don't have time for
anything see most people are hanging out
with people that have time that that
right there indicates that you're
hanging around people that got too much
time they're not obsessed and if you're
not hanging out with people that are
obsessed that understand obsess that
would give you permission to be obsessed
and never criticize you for it you know
what guess what you're not obsessed
because how would you even have time so
so um I would tell them look you don't
have the right people in your life by
the way that includes mommies daddies
brothers cuz
see my family knows like you're going to
either support me in my in the things
I'm doing or I just understand that
you're not on the team I don't there's
not for me there's either this team that
I'm on you know where we're people
around me will say do you could do that
you can do it no doubt you can do a
grant or there's everybody else
everybody else is a huge huge portion of
the population and so there's very very
few people like I tell this guy sells
his company for twenty 1 billion dollars
she's like grant hey what are you all
about we getting to know each other I
said man I want to meet I want 7 billion
people on this planet to know money you
know and he's like wow man that is a
worthy goal okay now you know and I know
you when I put piece of paper down and
say how do you meet seven billion people
you can't do it I don't have enough time
to do meet 7 billion people so most
people are going to tell me it's
impossible and never happened but I blah
blah right no not a god this gun
something you know so if I told Elon
Musk a man I want to meet every person
on human I want to get a book one of my
books to every person on planet Earth he
wouldn't say you can't he'd be like dude
if you can help me colonize Mars I can
help you get you a book they're human
see so see I know Elon would be a good
club to be an problem as Elon subsists
himself mm-hmm you know so look we live
on a planet that has a thing called
gravity you know he wants to defy and
and this gravity thing is much more you
know it's it's it's the average thing
gravity is affecting people's thinking
so that you're surrounded by people that
you need money to do it
you know something terrible is going to
happen fly under the radar you're going
to have your mom say
buteven f f we love you just the way you
are Evan you know all those are little
leaked outs dude of people that gave up
on their own accessions because your mom
and dad gave up my mom and dad
okay otherwise later already written
their own book because everybody's got a
book in good the people in the chat were
upset that the book was knocked over and
they want to make sure that's always in
frame so just so you know they're things
look at the cover okay but I like it man
just so you know they want to always in
frame to get that promotion out then
we're donating books to high schools
okay we donated up the ten thousand
almost 10,000 bucks already to high
schools and and we get the cover so that
so guy in the tenth grade because that's
where I went bad would you pick this up
you if you in the tenth grade doing you
in the library I like him oh I like your
flexibility in that picture for all I
want to see that happen I like it
that's not Photoshop okay I'll tell you
to be honest with you
the shoes are Photoshop yeah but but but
nothing else we tried to do it barefoot
it just cut I mean I did it this is my
shot this is not a Photoshop so I like
it
Rodrik a live viewers asking how do you
have the power to let go of those
negative people in your life you you
become like a you know you you become
like they're not going to even be
interested in look I got people that
have known me since I was born they have
no interest in me see because you start
vibrating at this other frequency you
know that that they're like dude I don't
want that you know I used to I used to
have these couple guys that I would
compete with a lot in a vertical my
first business and the problem is I
allowed them to compete with me because
I I basically vibrated in a similar
frequency and I limited myself to an
industry so they continue to think I was
there in their space well bro when I to
ramp it up and really started freaking
like really started fueling up obsession
next thing you know I'm not even in
their space don't see him I don't talk
to them I don't spend time with them I'm
just like I just like it
you know I popped out to another space I
pop out
to another universe if you will so so
for me it's it's not been about trying
to balance I think the whole work-life
balance thing is is uh I think it's a
myth men I would love for you anybody to
show me one person has pulled that deal
off and not giving up something so so
I'm doing my life man I think people
should do their life man today today
it's never been a better time for a
person to do it however you want to do
it too because like anything's possible
now but you don't want to compete with
people because the prom with competition
man is they are giving up on stuff they
are trying to do the life balance thing
I don't wake up in the morning try to be
a dad or a husband I don't wake up in
the morning saying I'm gonna be a
businessman today I wake up and say I'm
doing grant cardone today make me like
me love me I'm gonna do Kanye without
going broke because Kanye and Kanye had
figured it out either
Kanye does what he wants but the problem
is I went Shawne the other night at the
Staples Authority American Airlines yeah
I love Kanye's music absolutely love and
I wondered man when he gets off his
flying stage that he has okay when he
gets off the stage dude what's he gonna
do tonight is he going to go home and
get you know loaded is he going to go
home and get drunk or is he gonna have
something else than throwing himself
into this bro after you do 50,000 people
you better have something else to throw
yourself into otherwise you're going to
have this big giant boy so the way that
the way to feel the boy man is with
another activity some other purpose so
what do you want what is Grant Cardone
obsessed with right now many things man
you know the storm dude I'm diggin the
storm out right I can't wait I want to
see all the action we were down there
today periscope in it um but that's just
today that's just entertainment for me
right so right now look I'm trying to
take my 110 my real estate portfolio we
just create a public fun I just got
accredited by the SEC so now that I can
actually allow
let people come in and invest in my real
estate portfolio I want to take that
from four thousand units to forty
thousand units that's a big move right
there man I want to go ring to bail on
Wall Street and and uh so that's one
thing uh you know I just finished
writing this book so I'm never writing
another book this is it I'm gonna stick
I'm obsessed with say never ever am I
going to write another book um are you
gonna pull a Brett farmer though and
then like and then come back probably
all right problem but but uh you know
I'm very interested in changing the
school system
I want to see if I can actually affect
schools good school school was part of
the problem for me that's where I got so
much in this suppression and oppression
and stop and you know sit down sit there
for fifty five minutes I would never
make one of my kids sit somewhere for
fifty five so me it's not fair to the
kid so uh yeah man I'm obsessed with
seeing other parts of the world you know
I I wanna to shame that I don't speak
six other languages kind of limits you
when you got to go read meeting seven
billion people and you barely speak
English it's a problem talk to me about
building your platform and the reason
behind because if the goal is just money
you know there's tons of guys who've
made tons of cash you've never heard of
you can look at the wealthiest people in
the world and there's a bunch of guys
there that they don't have to have a
platform they just you could have just
kept doing your real estate thing built
it up and nobody would have heard grant
cardone but you'd be you know when the
richest guys around why is it important
to you like the message getting it out
there what's fueling that for you it's
because and this is a great question in
fact it's a question nobody's asked okay
like like I can tell that you've
actually thought about a why is this
dude doing this you know because if I
just wanted to get rich richer if I want
to just hit the four billion um all I
would do every day is buy real estate is
I know the game I know how to make money
I've done hundred of six or seven
hundred million dollars in transactions
I got about a half a billion dollars
whether real estate right now
you would never write a dumb book come
on again book sells for 17 dollars on
Amazon I get 13 or 14 percent of the
gross revenues good because there's no
money in that book okay it's a
tremendous amount of energy network but
one of the things that drives me if I
just made money if that's all I did
or just went around the country and
spoke and picked up my little my little
fee I would be back where I was when I
was 35 years old man which is feeling
burn out that's how I felt I felt burn
out I felt I was angry all the time I
was I was tired exhausted because
because and it's not because I was doing
too much is it's because I wasn't doing
enough of enough things to keep enough
variety to fill me up and like you know
if you're gonna burn one candle guess
what you're going to burn to the end of
that candle but if you keep a bunch of
candles lit I don't think you're going
to burn any of them out and you're gonna
create a tremendous amount light not for
others but for yourself so so that's
what's driving me man
what is the potential of grant cardone
and it's change you know when I was 25 I
just wanted to not use drugs when I was
35 I'm like damn I'm a I got a million
dollars man I'm like wow man you know
well hey can I turn that into ten then
I'm like then I realized oh hey I don't
have a girl
Here I am this good-looking dude
steadily like almost James Bond and
motion and posture and I don't have the
right chick dude I I'm you know I got
three and four chicks a week but I can't
keep I can't find the right one so I'm
like then I went on this thing to find
the right woman then she didn't want to
have anything to do with me then I'm
then I'm 50 and I'm like dude we got to
get a family man I want to have some
little little ones you know so so like
life changes as you go when I'm when I'm
70 years old or 80 I bought I bought a
plane last year and the reason I bought
that plane because that doesn't make
sense
is because dude I know I'm running out
of time
people like that house a plane makes
sense you know I said broke I'm running
out of time so that plane can get me
places faster and if you're not willing
to exchange money for time okay then
then what what am i what am I left with
people talk about me you showing the
plane off I'm like whatever dude I mean
I stream video okay I'm on a plane I
mean what can I tell you
should I go let me go give me somebody
else's little plane so everybody feels
better it's freaking neurotic right so
so I'm willing as you go through life
what at one time you like you need to
accumulate money and I understand that
and another time in life you need to use
the money to create the life you really
want and and so I don't know dude I
don't know what tomorrow brings you know
I hope it brings something I hope I wake
up with another idea I hope I wake up
with another fascination I hope there's
another carrot or something just out of
reach because that's when I'm happiest
it's not when I attain things but when
I'm chasing things is there anything
that for you has to get done before you
run out of time no I think it all gets
done after that did you know I I don't
think I'm a mortal body I'm not you know
I think it I think I see these guys
there's chruch man there's proof that
people live past the past their body you
know the guy you got over there over
your right shoulder dude
I mean he's been dead for two three or
four years Walt Disney dude he's been
dead for I don't know 30 years we still
talk about Jesus look at Jesus man all
these guys were obsessed everybody you
got on you all do they're freaks they're
freaks they're total freaks they're
aberrations of civilization okay they
are they are all in all the time [ __ ]
you I don't care if you like it do you
can talk about me bad maybe I hadn't
figured it all out but I'm gonna get one
area of my life right that's what Steve
Jobs did not Steve probably all that LSD
did back in the 70s
we screwed him up with his kids and his
wife and because the drugs will kill you
if they don't if you don't get them out
of your system
I'm talking from personal experience
right here to Steve he's probably
listening to me right now you need to
clean all that up because it'll affect
the spiritual entity that I believe
lives on past the body so so that's not
really Steve Jobs there that pictured
him as a picture of him you know this is
just my body and so you know I hope I
hope the day I die dude everybody's
going to have a party man and
everybody's going to help perpetuate my
work like when I when we do work today
I'm like hey what's that going to look
like 50 years from now
so whether whether it's whether I bought
an apartment building I'm like a kick in
my family can my estate he handle that
property 50 years from now what's the
plan and and by the way can some some
kids some seventeen year old kid and his
mama's renting an apartment from me at
nine hundred dollars a month could not
seventeen year old kid is he going to
have a safe environment is his mom gonna
be in a good space so that he's got a
better shot you know I'm not just
looking at that seven or eight hundred
bucks a month we collect from her hey is
that going to be a nice safe environment
like I don't do any Section eight for
that reason I don't do any Section eight
housing because I know once the
government gets involved in paying me
rent man I lost control of that property
so I want to be I want to vibrate most
people don't think I'm a very spiritual
person but actually underneath
everything all of it the James Bond I
want to be read you know I want to have
the hot chick do it I want people to
know me I want to be on a freaking
billboard you know dude underneath all
that is is it really just a spiritual
unit that's interested in it and
whatever a spiritual event being does
which would it he'd want to play and
have games and expand and and discover
life and try to move things around
because I can't be a football player
dude
sometimes I'm curious about the grant
cardone decision-making process you got
a guy here you know is got money he's
got an audience
he's got talent there's more
opportunities to have an impact than you
have time for you know with X amount of
years left
is it applying it into the education
system is it writing another book
it's not that is it traveling around the
world you know
how do you decide what the next thing is
is it is it you got a master planner is
that you know what I'm in the moment
whatever I feel I'm gonna go fire that
you know there was a I guess about I
don't know you got to put the buck up
they're gonna freak out man there you go
yes matin weeks ago I was in a charity
event I got this book rolling out you
know how much work how much how how much
work is involved in a book right so I
went to this charity event we raised two
million dollars there's two hundred
people in the room and that's a lot of
money for a couple hundred people and
the one guy did the last million
everybody's like oh my god you know we
were walking away everybody we're a
million dollar shark and then one guy
just walked up and says you know what
I'll do it and he drops the mic right
and the room freakin tripped out bro I
mean it the room lost it and I'm driving
home that night because I looked around
the room when it who did that right and
I looked around the room and every
person in that room wanted to be that
guy wanted to be the guy that could give
a million dollars away and and I came
home that night something happened I'm
answering your question here by the way
so we're rolling up that night and I'm
so jacked up dude I'm electrified and we
get home we lay down in bed and I said
Elena I'm gonna write a book tonight
now this one's already been done right
it's nineteen months to have this book I
sit down that night and I wrote a book
in two hours called the millionaire
booklet wrote it in 30 days we had it
translated into 38 languages then I
built a program called
grant cardone playbook familiar that
book that book that whole process was
not even anywhere had never even been
conceived to my knowledge or awareness
prior to that night so so to answer your
question man I'm just like I'm waiting
for data right like and it comes all the
time I'm just paying attention to it and
the other thing is I don't write about
anything that I haven't done or that I
it will help me I'm doing my life I'm
literally every all my books first
bookseller be sold but closure survival
God first year last all these books if
people really look at they want for
other people they were for me the first
book was seller be sold because 2009 the
economy collapsed and I was in a big
shot anymore I had to go back to selling
and so I'm like how do I do that now in
2009 and that book really was a
cathartic experience from mita to really
do some introspection about how do I
rebuild my business now that the economy
has has fallen apart and so all the
books have had that that story in it so
I don't have dude answer your question I
don't have a we don't I don't sit down
and I don't sit down on the side things
I like it man I like it yeah well it's
crazy how quickly half an hour flies by
you're getting a ton of love in the live
chat for people who are watching you can
go pick up grants book and if you email
in your receipt to obsessed at Grant
Cardone calm he's also going to give you
a credit for that amount in his store oh
this better send me a receipt and send
me a copy of the UH what you called the
review mmm Amazon Barnes and Noble books
a million and book depository target I
don't care what you buy the book from
okay but wherever you want to buy when
you buy write a review good or bad I
don't care you can give me one star no
stars three stars five just any review
that you can tell me I'm a dumbass dude
in the world
I don't care just do that because that's
a fair thing to do for somebody it
writes a book send me a copy of the
receipt and the review and I'll give you
a credit for the full amount in my store
if you buy ten books I'll give you
credit for the full amount in my store I
love it and that's so it's obsessed I
grant I don't calm you that's pretty
generous dude I don't know anybody's
ever done that before I love that I love
it man grants always given the value
that's what is out and in I forgot I'm
doing I'm doing a mastermind
starting October 13th for anybody that
buys the book uh if you send me your
receipt to obsessive grant cardone calm
I'll make you part of the mastermind is
13 weeks where I actually discussed the
book over thirteen week period each of
the chapters yes I love that I love to
make sure people actually read it and to
go over with you so every week you get
about 84 percent of books are not read
let's you know notice crazy you know you
know you know I know you know man but
when you write a book and you put your
heart into it and then nobody reads it
they buy 84 percent of people that buy
the book don't freaking read the book so
I'm like I'm gonna take responsibility
if you don't like to read by one copy
I'll make you part of the mastermind
I'll read the damn thing take it man I
love it man it's a great strategy yeah
I'm cool well thanks for spending your
time today thank you everybody for
watching our awesome bro and I'm gonna
help you out when your book comes out I
appreciate you let your people know
better alright let me know what I can do
to help
I will I will hit you up when we're
ready to go on that thanks men stay safe
a lot of a lot of stay safe comments
want to make sure you're good one last
shot of the book you guys say something
to get on though yeah yeah yeah oh dude
anybody can have a plane let me just
tell you that that should not be up that
should not be something out just
everybody should be obsessed I should be
one of the things you like dude you
should have your own bird I love it well
thank you grant
Evan thank you thanks for watching if
you need to believe and we'll see you
guys soon thanks Evan
you